mystery who's received a record 16
Academy Award nominations talks about
her background and career from New York
City this is a half hour
dry mouth Thank You president MS golden
president Tillman members of the Board
of Trustees distinguished faculty proud
swelling parents and family and gorgeous
class of 2010 if you are all really
really lucky and if you continue to work
super hard and you remember your thank
you notes and everybody's name and you
follow through on every task that's
asked of you and also somehow anticipate
problems before they even arise and you
somehow sidestep disaster and score big
if you get great scores on your LSAT or
EMM sets or ersatz or whatever and you
get into your dream grad school or
internship which then leads to a super
job with a paycheck commensurate with
the responsibilities of leadership or if
you somehow get that documentary edited
on a shoestring budget budget and then
it's accepted at Sundance and then maybe
it wins Sundance and then you go on to
be nominated for an Oscar and then you
win the Oscar or if that money making
website that you've designed with your
friends somehow suddenly attracts
investors and advertisers and becomes
the go-to site for whatever it is you're
selling blogging sharing or net cast
and success shining hoped for but never
really anticipated success comes your
way I guarantee you someone you know or
love will come to you and say will you
address the graduates at my college
and you'll say yeah sure when is it May
2010 2010 yeah
that's sure that's months away and then
the nightmare begins
the nightmare we've all had and III want
to assure you you will continue to have
even after graduation forty years after
graduation about a week before the due
date you wake up in the middle of night
I have a paper due and I haven't done
the reading oh my god if you have been
touched by the success fairy people
think you know why
I'm sure people think success breeds
enlightenment and you are duty-bound to
spread it around like manure fertilize
those young minds let them in on the
secret what is it that you know that no
one else knows the self-examination
begins one looks inward one opens an
interior door cobwebs black the lights
bulb bulbs burned out the airless dank
refrigerator of an insanely over
scheduled unexamined life that usually
just gets takeout where is my writer
friend Anna Quindlen when I need him on
another book tour hello my Meryl Streep
today class of 2010 I am really I am
very honored and I am humbled to be
asked to pass on tips and inspiration to
you for achieving success in this next
part of your lives
president spar when I when I consider
the other distinguished medal recipients
and the venerable Board of Trustees the
many accomplished faculty and family
members people who have actually done
things produced things while I have
pretended to do things
I can think of about 3800 people who
should have been on this list before me
and you know since my my success has
depended wholly on my putting things
over on people so I'm not sure the
parents really think I'm that great a
role model anyway I am however an expert
in pretending to be an expert in various
areas so just randomly like everything
else in this speech I am or I was an
expert in kissing on stage and on screen
how did I prepare for this well most of
my preparation for this was took place
at my suburban high school rather behind
my suburban high school in New Jersey
one is obliged to do a great deal of
kissing in my line of work air kissing
ass kissing kissing up and of course
actual kissing much like hookers actors
have to do it with people we may not
like or even know we may have to do it
with friends which is believe it or not
particularly awkward for people of my
generation it's awkward my other areas
of fo expertise river rafting miming the
effects of radiation poisoning knowing
which shoes go with which bag coffee
plantation in Polish German French
Italian that's Iowa tallien from the
Bridges of Madison County bit of a
brogue bit of the Bronx aramaic Yiddish
Irish clog dancing cooking singing
riding horses knitting playing the
violin and simulating steamy sexual
encounters these are some of the areas
in which I have pretended quite
proficiently to be successful or the
other way around as have many women here
I'm sure
women I feel I can say this
authoritative Lee especially at Barnard
where they can't hear us what am I
talking about they professionally can't
hear us women are better at acting than
men why because we have to be if
successfully convincing someone bigger
than you are of something he doesn't
want to know is a survival skill this is
how women have survived through the
millennia pretending is not just play
pretending is imagined possibility
pretending or acting is a very valuable
life skill and we all do it all the time
we don't want to be caught doing it but
nevertheless it's part of the adaptation
of our species we we change who we are
to fit the exigencies of our time and
not just strategically or to our own
advantage
sometimes sympathetically without our
even knowing it for the betterment of
the whole group I remember very clearly
my own first conscious attempt at acting
I was six
placing my mother's half slip over my
head in preparation to play the Virgin
Mary in our living room
as I swaddled my Betsy wetsy doll
I felt quieted holy actually and my
transfigured face and very changed
demeanor captured on super 8 by my dad
pulled my little brother's hairy for
playing Joseph and Dana to a barnyard
animal into the trance they they they
were actually pulled into this little
nativity scene by the the intensity of
my focus in a way that my usual
technique for getting them to do what I
want
yelling at them never ever would have
achieved and I learned something on that
day later when I was 9 I remember taking
my mother's eyebrow pencil and carefully
drawing lines all over my face
replicating the wrinkles that I had
memorized on the face of my grandmother
whom I adored I made my mother take my
picture and I look at it now of course I
look like myself now and my grandmother
then but I really do remember in my
bones how how it was possible on that
day to feel her age i stooped I felt
weighted down but cheerful you know I
felt like her empathy is at the heart of
the actor's art and in high school
another form of acting took hold of me I
wanted to learn how to be appealing so I
studied the character I imagined I
wanted to be that of the generically
pretty high school girl I researched her
deeply
that is to say shallowly
in vogue and 17 and Mademoiselle
magazines I tried to imitate her hair
her lipstick her lashes the clothes of
the lice and beautiful generically
appealing high school girls that I saw
in those pages I ate an apple a day
period I proc cited my hair I earned it
straight I demanded brand-name clothes
my mother shut me down on that one but I
did I worked harder on this
characterization really than any anyone
that I think I've ever done since I
worked on my giggle I I lightened it
because I liked it when it kind of went
off at the end because I thought it
sounded childlike and and cute this was
all about appealing to boys and at the
same time being accepted by the girls a
very tricky negotiation often success in
one area precludes succeeding in the
other and along with all of my exterior
choices I worked on what my what actors
call my interior adjustment I adjusted
my natural temperament which attended
ten tends to be slightly bossy little
opinionated loud little loud full of
pronouncements and high spirits and i
willfully cultivated softness
agreeableness breezy natural sort of
sweetness even a shyness if you will
which was very very very very very
effective on the boys
but the girls didn't buy it they didn't
like me they sniffed it out the acting
and they were probably right but I was I
was committed this was absolutely not a
cynical exercise this was a vestige of
survival courtship skill I was
developing and I reached a point senior
year when my adjustment felt like me I I
had actually convinced myself that I was
this person and she me pretty talented
but not stuck-up you know a girl who
laughed a lot at every stupid thing
every boy said and who lowered her eyes
at the right moment and deferred who
learned to defer when the boys took over
the conversation I really remember this
so clearly and I could tell it was
working I was much less annoying to the
guys than I had been they liked me
better and I liked that this was
conscious but it was at the same time
motivated and fully fully felt this was
real real acting I got to Vassar which
43 years ago was a single sex
institution like all the colleges and
what they called the Seven Sisters the
female Ivy League and I made some very
quick but lifelong and challenging
friends and with their help outside of
any competition for boys my brain woke
up
I got up and I got outside myself and I
I found myself again I didn't have to
pretend I could be goofy vehement
aggressive and slovenly and open and
funny and tough and my friends let me I
didn't wash my hair for three weeks once
they accepted me like The Velveteen
Rabbit I became real instead of an
imaginary stuffed bunny but I stuck
piled that character from high school
and I breathed life into her again some
years later as Linda in The Deer Hunter
there's probably not one of you
graduates who has ever seen this film
but the deer hunter it it won Best
Picture in 1978 Robert De Niro Chris
Walken not funny at all and I played
Linda a small-town girl from a
working-class background a lovely quiet
hapless girl who waited for the boys she
loved to come back from the war in
Vietnam often men my age President
Clinton by the way when I met him said
men my age mentioned that character as
their favorite of all the women I've
played
and I have my own secret understanding
of why that is and it confirms every
decision I made in high school this is
not to denigrate that girl by the way or
the men who are drawn to her in any way
because she's still part of me and I'm
part of her she wasn't acting but she
was just behaving in a way that cowed
girls submissive girls beaten up girls
with very few ways out have behaved
forever and still do in many worlds now
in a measure of how much the world has
changed the character most men mentioned
as their favorite is Miranda Priestly
the beleaguered totalitarian US at the
head of runway magazine Devil Wears
Prada to my mind this represents such an
optimistic shift they relate to Miranda
they wanted to date Linda they felt
sorry for Linda but they feel like
Miranda they can relate to her issues
the high standards she sets for herself
and others the thankless Nisour the
leadership position that nobody
understands me thing the loneliness they
stand outside one character and they
pity her and they kind of fall in love
with her but they look through the eyes
of this other character this is a huge
deal because as people in the movie
business know the absolute hardest thing
in the whole world is to persuade a
straight male audience to identify with
a woman protagonist to feel themselves
embodied by her this more than any other
factor explains why we get the movies we
get and the paucity of roles where women
drive the film
it's much it's much easier for the
female audience because we were all
brought up grown up identifying with
male characters from Shakespeare to
Salinger we have less trouble following
Hamlet's dilemma viscerally or Romeo's
or Tibbles
or Huck Finn or Peter Pan I remember
holding that sword up to hook I felt
like in but it is much much much harder
for heterosexual boys to be able to
identify with Juliet or Desdemona or
Wendy in Peter Pan or Joe and Little
Women or the little mermaid or
Pocahontas why I don't know but it just
is there has always been a resistance to
imaginatively assume a persona if that
persona is a sheen the things are
changing now and it's in your generation
that we're seeing this men are adapting
about time
they are adapting consciously and also
without realizing it for the better of
the whole group they're changing their
deepest prejudices to accept and to
regard as normal things that their
fathers their fathers would have found
very very difficult and their
grandfathers would have abhorred and the
door into this emotional shift is
empathy as young said emotion is the
chief source of becoming conscious there
can be no transforming of likeness into
dark of apathy into movement without
emotion or as Leonard Cohen says pay
attention to the cracks because that's
where the light gets in you young women
of Barnard have not had to squeeze
yourselves into the corset of being cute
or to muffle your opinions but then you
haven't left campus yet I just can just
kidding you have had what you have had
is the privilege of a very specific
education you are people that may be
able to draw on a completely different
perspective to imagine to imagine a
different possibility than women and men
who went to co-ed schools how this
difference is going to really serve you
it's it's hard to quantify now you may
may take you 40 years like it did me to
look back and analyze your advantage but
today is about looking forward into a
world where so-called women's issues
human issues of gender inequality live
at the very crux of the global problems
everyone suffers from poverty to the age
crisis the rise in violent
fundamentalist hunters human trafficking
and human rights abuses
and you are going to have the
opportunity and the obligation by virtue
of your provenance to speed progress in
all these areas and this is a place
where even though the need is very great
the news is - this is your time and it
feels normal to you but really there is
no normal
there's only change and resistance to it
and then more change never before in the
history of our country have most of the
advanced degrees been awarded to women
but now they are since the dawn of man
it's hardly more than a hundred years
since we were even allowed into these
buildings except to clean them but soon
most of the law and medical degrees will
probably also go to women around the
world poor women now own property who
used to be property and according to the
Economist magazine for the last two
decades the increase in female
employment in the rich world has been
the main driving force of growth those
women have contributed more to global
GDP growth than have either new
technology or the new giants India or
China cracks in the ceiling cracks in
the door cracks in the court and on the
Senate floor
you know I gave a speech at Vassar 27
years ago it was a really big hit
everybody loved it really Tom Brokaw
said it was the very best commencement
speech he had ever heard and of course I
believed this and you know it was much
much easier to construct than this one
it it came out pretty easily because
back then I knew so much I was a new
mother I had a I had an account I had to
I had two Academy Awards and it was all
you know coming together so nicely I was
smart and I understood boiler plate and
what sounded good and because I'd been
on the squad in high school
earnest full throated cheerleading was
my specialty so that's what I did but
now I feel like I know about 1/16 of
what that young woman knew things don't
seem as certain today now I'm 60 I have
four adult children who are all facing
the same challenges that you are I'm
more sanguine about all the things that
I still don't know and I am still
curious about what I do know about
success fame celebrity that would fill
another speech how it separates you from
your friends from reality from
proportion your own sweet anonymity a
treasure you don't even know you have
until it's gone how it makes things
tough for your family and whether being
famous matters really one bit in the end
and the whole flux of time I know I was
invited here because of there
how famous I am and how many awards I've
won and and while I am I am overweening
Li proud of the work that I believe me
did not do on my own I can assure you
that awards have very little bearing on
my own personal happiness my own sense
of well-being and purpose in the world
that comes from studying the world
feeling Li with empathy in my work it it
comes from staying alert and alive and
involved in the lives of the people that
I love and the people in the wider world
who need my help
no matter what you see me or hear me
saying when I'm on your TV holding a
statuette and spewing that's acting
being a celebrity has taught me to hide
but being an actor has opened my soul
being here today has forced me to look
around inside there for something useful
that I can share with you and I'm I'm
really grateful that you gave me the
chance you know you don't have to be
famous you just have to make your mother
and father proud of you and you already
have new British Prime Minister